severodonezk es actualmente la ciudad de
la provincia el lugar más al este que se
encuentra en control de las tropas
ucranianas sin embargo las fuerzas rusas
no están muy lejos de aquí y algunas
versiones dicen que estarían a menos de
dos kilómetros en algún sector a cuatro
en el otro lo único que sabemos es que
se oyen explosiones permanentemente sin
embargo hoy es un día relativamente
tranquilo comparado con los días
anteriores cuando esta ciudad fue
atacada severamente la mayoría de la
población se ha partido ya hace bastante
tiempo sin embargo encontramos grupos de
personas reunidos en varias entradas de
sus casas que han decidido quedarse a
pesar de la situación muchos de ellos
dicen que tienen que cocinar en las
calles los vemos con hornos de leña no
tienen agua no tienen electricidad
muchos de ellos van con bidones tratando
de buscar cómo abastecerse y la mayoría
de ellos no tienen alimentos dicen que
están pasando bastante hambre así que
algunas misiones de voluntarios les
traen algunos provisiones para
sobrevivir esta etapa tan dura pero la
medida va pasando el tiempo es más
difícil acceder a esta población cada
vez más asediada los militares nos han
dicho que la situación es regular pero
que esperan tener el control total en
los próximos días